[російською] Все, поїхали?
[російською] Ой, дівчата дорогі,
так до нас же гості прийшли.
[російською] Дорогі гості, Любо.
[російською]
♪ До нас гості прийшли, дорогі гості прийшли. ♪
♪ Не даремно ми локшину варили і млинці пекли. ♪
[російською]
♪ Так, наше село дружбою славиться. ♪
[російською] ♪ Приїжджайте в гості частіше,
якщо вам у нас сподобається. ♪
[російською] А зараз будуть стружки.
[російською] Хто закодований (від алкоголю),
тому сьогодні стружок не буде.
[російською] Специфічний запах.
А взагалі ми горілку додаємо.
[російською] От і ніж прибув для локшини.
[російською] Ось цим ножем будемо різати.
Мої пращури були вислані
царським урядом з Владімірської губернії, Росії.
Вислані за віру.
Це мій прадід і прабабуся.
А мама вже народилась тут.
Її мама, моя бабуся, народилась тут.
Ну і, звичайно, ми з сестрою, в Нововасилівці.
Я виросла тут, я закінчила Нововасилівську школу, пишаюсь.
Люблю своє село, люблю свою школу, люблю людей.
Це моя батьківщина, це моя Україна.
[російською] Будинок під номером 71 на вулиці Кооперативна,
на центральній вулиці селища Нововасилівка, — один з найстаріших.
[російською] Оскільки побудований він у 1857 році.
[російською] Саме молоканство виникло ще в 10 столітті.
[російською] Коли християнство було на межі розпаду,
виникли так звані секти.
[російською] У перекладі з латини секта — «школа».
[російською] Тобто це інше тлумачення християнства.
[російською] Це наша світлиця, горниця.
[російською] А молокани називали її залою.
[російською] Найбільша та найсвітліша кімната,
де приймали гостей.
[російською] Ми тут теж приймаємо гостей,
ми тут самі збираємося.
[російською] В цій кімнаті у молокан, звісно ж, був стіл,
за який можна було посадити гостей.
[російською] Стіл, за яким читали Євангеліє,
співали духовні пісні, молилися.
[російською] У цій кімнаті обов'язково була тепла піч. Плитки не було.
[російською] Процес зародження тепла був прихований.
[російською] А от дух від плитки був у грубці.
[російською] Цього року нарешті здійснилася наша мрія.
[російською] Чотири дні тому майстер
за чотири дні виклав ось таку красу.
[російською] Першою думкою було — зберегти будівлю,
створити тут музей.
[російською] Музей побуту першопоселенців.
[російською] А перші поселенці — вихідці духовні
християни-молокани з Тамбовської та Владімірської губернії Царської Росії,
[російською] які були гнані царським урядом, самодержавством.
[російською] І вони приїхали сюди для того,
щоб зберегти свою віру, культуру і духовність.
[російською] Стружки, хрустики.
А у цих — вергуни (українська страва).
[російською] Ні, вергуни грубші і на кислому молоці.
[російською] Вони вивертаються теж так, як хрустики.
[російською] А замість соди ми наллємо...
[російською] Сто грамів.
— [російською] Це горілка.
— [російською] Це самогон.
[російською] Щось він мутний якийсь.
[російською] Чому мутний? Він на травах.
[російською] З [молоканською] кипельними фіранками.
[російською] Коли дітки приходять на екскурсію,
ми трішки згадуємо молоканську лексику.
[російською] Мова дуже цікава.
[молоканською] Кипельні [фіранки]...
[російською] Я чому питаю: «Діти, що це таке?»
[російською] Хто з дітей знає, хто не знає.
Я кажу: «А чи ви бачили, як кипить вода?
[російською] Пінка з'являється. Якого вона кольору?
[російською] Біла. Якщо вода чиста, піна сліпучо біла».
[російською] От кипельні фіранки,
кипельні скатертини у виставковій залі.
[російською] А ще у нас є бабусина
[молоканською говіркою] кімнатка.
[російською] Знову ж таки в російській мові
є зменшувально-пестливі суфікси.
[російською] «Кімнатка» з наголосом на корінь слова,
а молокани казали: «комнатка».
[російською] Ласкаво просимо до
[молоканською говіркою] кімнати.
[російською] Екскурсії приїжджають.
І вчителі були у нас в гостях, і працівники культури.
[російською] Всіх просимо:
якщо у вас є щось цікаве, приносьте.
[російською] І так нововасилівці, гості наші — всі нам несли.
[російською] Молокани дуже працьовиті,
проворні і жили у достатку.
[російською] А коли прийшла епоха розкуркулення...
[російською] Коли, якщо ти працюєш і живеш в достатку,
[російською] і твої діти нагодовані, і врожай хороший,
і поля доглянуті, значить ти — куркуль.
[російською] Значить тут тобі не місце, ділись.
[російською] А ділили по-варварському, жорстоко.
Все забирали, до останнього шматка хліба.
[російською] У мене також сім'я репресованих.
[російською] Я, так би мовити,
правнучка репресованої людини.
[російською] І щоби це не розтопталося,
не спалилося, не розікралося,
[російською] в оцю супницю, під лахміття і тряпки.
[російською] І робилось це не через скупість,
не для того, щоб втримати своє.
[російською] А просто для того,
що от внуки виростуть: а раптом виживуть,
[російською] а раптом не вб'ють їх,
а раптом голодом не заморять?
[російською] От для них і буде. І вивезли.
[російською] І ось через 85 років ця супниця
потрапила до нас як експонат.
[російською] Як історія життя однієї сім'ї.
[російською] Це окрема, дуже хвилююча,
історія, яка знаєте, ранить, іноді.
[російською] Ми просто горді, що змогли зберегти її.
Пам'ятаємо цю історію і ніколи її не забудемо. Нізащо.
[російською]
♪ Під високим вікном вишня білосніжна цвіте. ♪
♪ Повз цю вишню, повз цю хату ♪
[російською]
♪ Хлопець бравий перший раз іде. ♪
♪ Повз цю вишню, повз цю хату ♪
[російською]
♪ Хлопець бравий перший раз іде. ♪
Був один факт в моєму житті.
Це було пов’язано з тими подіями,
які відбуваються зараз на Сході [України].
Через мою вулицю пройшли перші добровольчі батальйони.
Ця техніка, на якій сиділи ось такі молоді хлопці,
майже як мої сини, вони їхали туди.
[Вони їхали] захищати нашу Батьківщину.
А я йшла в музей.
Потім прийшла сюди і розказала,
що діти поїхали туди.
А була тиша, мене ніхто не чув.
І мені сказали: «Володимирівна, [російською] а твої діти?»
[російською] А я їм кажу: «Я їх не ховатиму».
[російською] І вони у мене не ховатимуться.
[російською] Як треба буде, то встануть і підуть,
тому що це наша земля.
[російською] Це наша Батьківщина.
[російською] Інакше й бути не може, совість не дозволить.
[російською] Я буду плакати, буду чекати,
буду молитися за них.
[російською] Молитимусь, щоб у них все було добре,
і щоб інші діти не гинули.
[російською] І щоб, врешті-решт, матері більше не плакали.
[російською] Щоб нарешті настав мир.
Дотепер я цього хочу.
[російською] Ось так.
І що найважливіше, мабуть, що це поклик розуму.
Коли людина, обдумавши все, робить висновок.
І визначає напрям свого життя.
У нас на Запоріжжі, на Хортиці,
проводиться фестиваль «Барвиста Хортиця».
Усі культури: греки, молдовани, росіяни... Всі їдуть.
[російською] Усі їдуть туди. І ми теж беремо участь.
[російською] Представляємо наш район.
Разом з друзями, з болгарами.
[російською] Дуже тісна дружба у нас.
[російською] Можливо, ми щось робимо не так.
[російською] Можливо, хтось скаже,
що так робити не треба.
[російською] Ось так ми живемо.
[російською] Іноді, можливо, коли зовсім сіра смуга в житті піде,
[російською] кажу: «Ну все, зовсім нічого вже не буде».
[російською] А потім, все одно приходимо,
тому що є ще Нововасилівка,
[російською] є ще частина життя, яку хочеться прожити,
щоб не просто безслідно, щоб ...
[російською] Це потім уже здається,
ой, глянь, а скільки зробили.
[російською] А ось так душа тягнеться,
рветься і робимо, і все.
[російською] Не пишаємося, ні.
Скоріш за все, він просто наш.
[російською] От він такий рідний.
[молоканською говіркою]
♪ Вздовж по вулиці молодик часто ходить, ♪
♪ Він на Тетянине віконце часто поглядає. ♪
[молоканською говіркою]
♪ І з тобою під вінець відправлялася. ♪